ability is something that's super
important to people the ability not just
to move upwards but to move sideways in
organizations that there's room to learn
and grow and that you don't have to
leave a company in order to change your
role
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to meet tracy werner head of
communications and employer brand at
cognite tracy is a passionate
communications leader obsessed with
getting the right message to the right
people at the right time every touch
point in her career has entailed
storytelling and raised the bar of
communications in corporate settings in
her current role she leads the team
responsible for communication internal
and pr employer brand social media and
video tracy grew up in south africa and
now lives in israel with her husband and
three kids tracy werner welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
joining me from the cognite offices
right yes in here yeah thank you michael
how are you wonderful i'm doing great
thank you very very much you mentioned
that usually you're the one sitting in
my seat and and so we shared how you
know this this is a different different
situation but i'm excited to have this
conversation with you about this idea of
communication but in the world of
communication employer branding and and
what that even means i think that you
know it's a growing
term that we're seeing more and more
today
certainly not one that we saw a few
years ago very frequently but but we
understand now the importance of it with
cognite you have the privilege of owning
the employer branding strategy for quite
a few employees you'll share some of the
numbers with me
shortly but i'm excited to pick your
brain on on both the importance of it
but then more tangibly how does it work
you know besides just the posters and
the billboards and the quotes how do you
actually create an atmosphere where
people feel acknowledged and feel
they're a part of something meaningful
and so tracy we have a lot to talk about
tell me a little bit about you and how
you ended up finding yourself in the
world of employer branding all the way
from almost being a hollywood actress
so that was certainly the dream once
upon a time uh i'll be perfectly honest
employer branding is fairly new to me i
my comfort zone has always been in
communications in all sorts of forms
i've been in communication roles for 20
years and a year ago i joined cognite
as it was setting itself up for a
spin-off from varrent
and we were doing a rebrand we were
establishing ourselves with a new name
in the market we provide security
analytics software and we needed to
position ourselves properly and we
needed to make sure that as a company
our employer brand would remain strong
coming with a legacy of 25 years but a
new name so you're trying to recruit
employees you're trying to get them to
know what the company is and they've
never heard the name before so we have a
lot to do
i'm responsible for internal
communication for pr which is the
external communication social media and
employer branding but they're really a
family they all work so beautifully
together and all of them sit within the
domain of marketing at cognite which i
think works really well
with what employer branding is and i
think because i'm new to the to the role
to the industry i'll first of all say
that i'm very lucky in cognite because
i've got an amazing team
so i'm learning a lot from the people
who work um for me i've got a fantastic
employer brand manager and i've got a
manager who comes our cmo understands
this world and saw the importance of it
very very early on so we've been
investing in employer brand for a long
time but it's fairly new and in the last
year or two it has simply blown up
globally it's become
the profession it's become one of the
most important things any company has so
what is it
yes
if you think of regular branding in
marketing if you're selling a product
it's how people perceive the value that
your product brings
employer branding is just the same it's
about how
potential employees and existing
employees look at the company how they
feel when they hear the name what they
think the company does and the value
they think the company would bring if
they were going to join the company or
if they're going to talk about the
company to other people so it's how
people see and perceive your company
it's the brand the company has
externally and that's how people talk
about it inside and outside the company
so that's that's what employer brand is
why has it become so much more important
today
with covert a lot of people stayed very
static at the beginning they didn't want
to move people were moving to home
and then
things started getting back on track
they got used to it it was easier to
interview they started becoming
interested in other companies i think in
a lot of respects people felt like one
thing they could change in this huge
mess the world had become
was where they worked
and the job market went
ballistic
quite amazing to see people started
moving from all sorts of companies big
small startups settled
uh corporate not corporate people
started to move and the employer brand
became critical not just to retain
employees not just to say guys there's a
lot of great stuff happening in the
company you can move to
but also externally to say if you're
going to move come to us
so that's where that's where the impact
of employer brand has has really taken
foot
today
right now when we talk about you know
employer branding in a more tangible way
and obviously we want employees to be
attracted to the brand of the company
and to feel welcomed and this is both
you know internally to existing
employees but also to attract new
employees but how does that actually
work how do you actually manage a
strategy for employer branding is it
mainly in you know in gifts that you
give employees and the writing on the
wall are there different you know ways
of thinking through creating this
employer branding
right so it's a great question because a
lot of people think employer branding is
big parties and billboards
and it's so much more than that of
course the employee experience is
critical but it's so much more a lot of
them think it's this kind of thing you
know the swag
and stuff we all get someone asked me in
israel a while ago what swag stood for
so it's stuff we all get
um
but it's so much more than that it's
deeply strategic first of all it has to
align with the business goals it has to
align with whether you want to grow you
work very closely with the teams in the
the people teams the hr teams for
recruiting purposes so it's much more
than just stuff that you know you see on
social media where people are having fun
i think for me the most important thing
in the strategy is that
the employees need to relate to it they
need to feel like they own it it needs
to be authentic
interesting for example
companies who have employer branding
strategies develop something called an
evp which is an employer value
proposition
and this is this is the
dna
of the company that you that you try to
communicate to the external world the
way that they did it over here and i say
they because i wasn't part of the
amazing team that did the work but then
a
process was run
um incognito several years ago before we
became cognite to develop the evp
we brought in consultants we had round
tables with employees we deep dived into
what makes employees excited about
working here what differentiates this
company from other companies you need to
understand that we're competing with
companies like google and facebook
they're really big giants we're also
competing with niche players um but we
do something that's that's sought after
and we need to compete with a range and
we looked at what are the things that
differentiate us and differentiate the
employee experience
for people who are looking at joining us
so
following that process and hearing the
employees voices we came up with three
main elements that were that really
identify us as a company um it's the
people it's the fact that there's the
ability to move and grow and learn and
and change roles within the company so
there's that
it's uh as a company it's what our
purpose is the fact that we work
together to make the world a safer place
critical today and it to have a real
purpose uh people want to work for a
place that's you know that's doing good
and the technology the challenges people
are dealing with they're dealing with
some of the most complex challenges in
the world and the company addresses that
need we've got some really brilliant
people over here right so when we sat in
those meetings even when i joined and i
wanted to understand more what drives
them i said to them what are the
languages i should be talking about on
social media and they said to me never
mind the language we smart enough to
work out what language is needed and how
to learn it give us the challenges tell
us what needs to be solved we'll find
the solution
that was really interesting to me and
when we looked at those three things
that the people at the purpose at the
technology and brought them all together
we realized that the theme of curious
appears in all of them the the
the value proposition of curiosity was
really what brought it all together and
took that triangle and took it to the
next level and that's that's the brand
that we that we chose and then rolled
out
what happens the next morning so you you
have that aha moment okay curiosity this
is a
this is a core piece of what we're
building here and who we are as an
organization and as a business but then
what happens the next day
wow so first of all you talked about
planning earlier right so it's all about
the strategy now you've got the you've
got your
your value proposition then you need to
think how do i take this and how do i
get it out there you validate it with
the employees you look globally because
indifference in different areas you've
got different things that appeal to the
population so you look globally at
what's going to appeal to each and then
you look at how you can communicate
all of those areas so for example in
israel and in several other countries
around the world we had a curiosity club
where we had people that were coming to
listen to lectures and that were this
was before covert when people could come
in person and to hear about topics that
related to curiosity that related to
technology not even necessarily to our
world but to interests that our
employees had that we thought other
people would be interested in so that's
one of the things that we did we've done
recently we understood that with the the
bubbling market that we're dealing with
or even the boiling market we're dealing
with mobility is something that's super
important to people the ability not just
to move upwards but to move sideways in
organizations that there's room to learn
and grow and that you don't have to
leave a company in order to change your
role so we've done a campaign on digital
media around mobility we asked employees
to talk about it we showed videos we've
got some very cool animated videos that
really show the story of real employees
who have moved over the years from one
role to another either laterally or
upwards
that's really bringing in a lot of
attention um we try to thread the
language of our value proposition
through everything that we do so when i
said that it's not just about parties
and billboards it's also about digital
campaigns that you monitor that you
optimize it's
perfect marketing methodology just being
used with people and and potential
recruits and the name of the company
rather than with products that you that
you're trying to sell and people who are
buying those products
now
a little bit of a weird question how do
you know that it's working
how would because you know when i
develop software or when i solve
mathematical equations i i know sort of
when i'm on the right track right i can
see my accuracy and my precision with my
ai models but
with something like employer branding
how do i know whether i'm doing a good
job or not
so it's a fantastic question and there
are two answers to that and it was
probably the first question that that
came up when i joined and i started
learning this role i was like but how do
i know it works i love it
i put it online and i don't see that
many people are sharing it so i didn't
go viral how do i know that a specific
campaign has worked
there are scientific ways that you go in
and you analyze the results so if you
have a campaign we measure it like we
would any other marketing campaign it
goes through a funnel where you you know
you expose people to it and then you see
who clicked on it and went through to
the website and you can actually see
from many many hundreds of people who
are exposed to campaigns that are
targeted for specific audiences in
specific countries how many in the end
send their cvs but it's a very
challenging thing i can tell you for
example we have offices in europe we've
seen in romania and in bulgaria takes
around 14 touch points before somebody
will submit a cv
wow
it's unbelievable which means that they
need to have seen the website you need
to have reached them on social media you
need to know where they're surfing so
that you've got your pr out there in the
right places and you've got your
campaigns out in the right places and
when you call them you need to know what
kind of interactions they've already had
so you really have to be on the ball
just like you would be with any other
marketing campaign we had a campaign
earlier this year when we did the
spin-off it was quite amazing so for the
spin-off this is where everything that i
do comes together the internal
communications getting employees on
board getting the name out there we
shared with 2 000 employees what the new
name was three months
before we launched the new name
externally and by you know there's a
joke that if you want to turn the secret
between two people one of them needs to
be dead
yeah
yeah you had two thousand people who
kept a secret because they were in it it
was theirs they felt the sense of
belonging and over unbelievable
so so that's really that's really what
we do so with the spin-off right we had
this amazing internal communication
campaign
and then we did all sorts of things we
sent all the swag to employees homes
because we were still at home with
covert we did a beautiful event around
the spin-off when we went on to nasdaq
from our management's homes
and we at the end of it all we saw that
employees created a viral campaign all
by themselves
posting pictures of the stuff they got
we had pictures of their pets all over
social media they were sometimes tagging
us sometimes not tagging us it was
unbelievable to see what happened from
employees and you can also see that that
affected the campaign so we had a
campaign around the rebrand around the
new name who we are to get our brand
awareness there with potential employees
and when you look at the numbers
afterwards we realized that we got
hundreds of cvs even though we weren't
even trying to recruit at the time
specifically with this campaign hundreds
of cvs came in as a result of one or
more of the touch points that we worked
on so
numbers but i said there's two things
the numbers is one the other it's like
any other marketing activity gut
instinct it's is this going to work it's
all people talking about it how excited
are employees getting about this are
they sharing
perhaps i can give you one more example
of something that was amazing
so first of all i joined here and i've
got this huge scope and i realized we
kept going outside the office to record
things
and i said you know let's build a studio
in the office so we built a little
studio on the first floor did i mention
already that our cmo has vision right i
just said that we need this so we did it
and in the studio we have all sorts of
things we have a specific role at the
moment that we're looking for in the
company maybe by the time this is
broadcast it will have been full but
we're looking for a global head of
recruiting and the person hiring for it
is amazing she's dynamic she's fun she's
really great and we're having a hard
time to fill the role so we took her
into the studio
took 20 minutes and recorded her
and realized that actually the bloopers
from the recording were even more
interesting than the recording itself
wow we posted a video where she kind of
pulls a little fun at herself she laughs
at herself a bit she speaks about some
of the terms we use in job postings that
are overused
and if i tell you this thing has gone
wild
and it wasn't a big investment we did it
in the house our video manager did it
sometimes you just don't know but
sometimes your gut instinct tells you
this is the way to go and you need to go
with it whether the numbers the
point that way or not i i just love it i
love it and i and i
i wish that i i could spend more time
you know just diving into this world
myself because i think that it's just
such such a
fascinating idea how do you get people
on board and you know today we're
talking about you know salaries and
equity and all that stuff but at the end
people want to feel welcomed and they
want to feel part of something great and
i and it's going to take me some time to
reflect back on this idea of keeping a
secret amongst 2 000 people for three
months
and it's not a small secret it's a
pretty big it's a pretty big deal i'm
sure that everybody understood that and
so it's going to take me a bit of time
to reflect on how how that even happened
and if i were in your shoes what i would
do today so i'm going to be asking you
some questions after this episode
because this is just fascinating uh but
but tracy really thank you for the time
and thank you for sharing with me you
know your own perspective and your own
journey and i can't believe you're only
at this employer branding for a year and
it sounds really really exciting and and
fascinating a little bit about you you
know take me back
you know as far back as elementary
school middle school back then were you
also really interested in communications
and culture or
were you fascinated by other things i
love people and i love talking
i was always gonna you joked about it
and being an actress i always plan to be
an actress i used to practice my oscars
speech so i've always had roles where i
could talk to people my formal education
is in counseling but even there and i'm
an english teacher but even there it's
about bringing people together and
making sure that messages get across so
yes i think communication really runs
through my blood
i love it and if you had to choose a few
words for yourself tracy that you would
use to describe yourself
what would they be
um empathetic
i would say that i'm motherly i have
three kids of my own but i think that
the people around me in general feel
like there's a mother hen in me
ambitious and caring
i love it tracy thank you very very much
and i can't wait to hear more stories
about about employer branding is
especially as we're talking about
thousands of people you know it's one
thing to to work on building a culture
with you know a few dozen people or even
a few hundred people but when you're
thinking strategically about how to
build a culture that is going to suit
thousands of people and such a company i
think that's just a different ballgame
and requires a little bit of different
thinking thank you very very much tracy
stay friends stay stay safe and stay
healthy and until next time and i just
want to say thank you so much for giving
me the platform and i think it's really
easy at the end of the day when you work
in a company with an amazing culture
that's my legacy
thank you
[Music]